hello I'm Ryan and on David and we're
reviewing edge of tomorrow and a monday
morning review with a side of spoilers
so you don't want spoilers watch the
movie first then come back to us David
first impressions overall I thought this
movie was great it's a perfect blend of
a groundhog day in action I really
enjoyed the movie as well um the one
thing that really really surprised me
was kind of how funny and clever and
witty the movie was yeah i think the
script is very very well-constructed I
feel like whoever wrote this had like
hundreds of index cards planning out
everything to me there's really only a
few holes it really handles when you
have anything we're like the same things
are happening over again um filmmakers
always have to set up these visual cues
that you don't have to see everything
over and over again and i think doug
liman does a really really good job of
that i think that another movie that
kind of did that was source code they
had a good kind of rhythm to it I do
need to speak about Tom Cruise I mean
lately the last few years his his work
has not been as well received as it has
in the past um for me this was like a
return to form for him hehe truly is
like an amazing movie star yeah Tom
Cruise lights up the screen I mean I
love Minority Report Jerry Maguire for
certain Tom Cruise movies I'm not really
a fan of but i think that like this is
definitely one of the a movies for Tom
Cruise the marketing campaign and the
color palette also kind of has this like
muted kind of gives the impression that
this could be like a dead serious kind
of movie um and it's not like in our
theater people were laughing all over
the place him and Emily Blunt have
really good chemistry the thing that
this movie really is going forward is
that the cast is is legit like these are
real actors doing these things yeah I
love seeing bill paxton again he's great
movies
him as the military officer and like
Emily Blunt brings the great amount of
action heroine ISM to this movie I mean
she she's a total badass in this I've
seen her in like the devil wears prada
it's a completely different performance
or is there anything David that you had
reservations about so the ending I'm not
really a fan of so spoilers is that
there's a sort of big explosion from the
Alpha Omega alien and then we go back to
like the very beginning of the movie and
I just it confused me a lot I'm I
remember leaving a theater being like
that ending really kind of ruins the
movie like and then I did some reading
online there's some good articles to
explain what happened yeah I feel like I
have a splendid day wiggle I feel like a
movie should i shouldn't have to go on
the internet and like read in a
description of how the ending especially
especially for a movie that could have
been so convoluted and is so clear
that's very true um I think that that
was kind of a misstep there's been a lot
of writing about how it was changed from
the original script a lot but it really
does have a good sense of like
escalating motion throughout there's
great momentum with the movie I mean the
special effectiveness are just amazing
like they never end to I mean everything
has significant amount of visual like
energy going on in 3d yeah so go see
edge of tomorrow it's an awesome sci-fi
action yep and it's not getting nearly
the business that it should be getting
if you're a fan of source code
Groundhog's Day any action movie Tom
Cruise Emily Blunt I mean a lot of
things you like about this but
especially like these sort of time loop
movies maybe loopers an example Elysium
his ins but as far as exoskeleton movies
when I think action I think Groundhog
Day
anyway until next time please comment
below and let us know what you thought
the better tomorrow I'm Ryan I'm David
thank you for watching